y casi nunca se ha explorado.
Ese lugar se llama la estratosfera.
Si uno comienza en el planeta y sube, sube y sube,
hace más y más y más frío,
hasta llegar al inicio de la estratosfera,
y luego una cosa increíble sucede.
Hace más frío a un ritmo mucho más lento y luego comienza a calentar,
y luego se pone más y más caliente
hasta el punto de que casi se puede sobrevivir sin ningún tipo de protección,
aproximadamente cero grados,
y luego al final es más y más frío,
y esa es la parte superior de la estratosfera.
Es uno de los lugares menos accesibles en nuestro planeta.
Muy a menudo, cuando se ha visitado,
es por los astronautas que se lanzan a ella
en probablemente varias veces la velocidad del sonido,
y consiguen estar unos segundos en el camino,
y luego son esta bola ardiente de fuego que entra de nuevo,
en el camino de vuelta.
Pero la pregunta que hice es, ¿es posible permanecer en la estratosfera?
¿Es posible experimentar la estratosfera?
¿Es posible explorar la estratosfera?
La estudié usando mi buscador favorito
durante bastante tiempo, alrededor de un año,
y luego hice una llamada telefónica de miedo.
Era una referencia de un amigo mío que se llama Taber MacCallum
de la Corporación de Desarrollo Espacial Paragon,
y le hice la pregunta:
¿es posible construir
un sistema para ir a la estratosfera?
Y él dijo que sí.
Y después de unos tres años, procedimos a hacer precisamente eso.
Y el 24 de octubre del año pasado,
con este traje,
empezando desde el suelo,
subí 41 420 m en un globo,
pero ¿quién está contando?
(Risa)
Volvimos a la Tierra a una velocidad de hasta 1323 km por hora.
Fue un descenso de 4 minutos y 27 segundos.
Y cuando estaba a 3 050 m, abrí un paracaídas y aterricé.
(Aplausos)
Pero esto es realmente una charla de ciencia y una charla de ingeniería,
y lo que fue increíble para mí de esa experiencia
es que Taber dijo, sí, creo que podemos construir un traje estratosférico,
y más que eso, ven mañana
y hablaremos con el equipo que formó el núcleo del grupo
que realmente lo construyó.
E hicieron algo que creo que es importante,
tomaron la analogía del buceo.
En el buceo,
uno tiene un sistema autónomo.
Uno tiene todo lo que se pueda necesitar.
Una escafandra autónoma de buceo.
Un traje de neopreno.
Visibilidad.
Y esa escafandra es exactamente este sistema,
y lo lanzaremos a la estratosfera.
Tres años más tarde, esto es lo que tenemos.
Tenemos un traje increíble hecho por ILC Dover.
ILC Dover fue la empresa que hizo que todos los trajes del Apolo
y todos los trajes de la actividad extravehicular.
Nunca habían vendido un traje comercialmente,
solo para el gobierno,
pero me vendieron uno a mí, por lo que estoy muy agradecido.
A partir de aquí hay un paracaídas. Esto era todo por seguridad.
Todos en el equipo sabían
que tengo esposa y dos hijos pequeños
de 10 y 15 años,
y yo quería volver seguro.
Hay pues un paracaídas principal y un paracaídas de reserva,
y si no hago nada,
el paracaídas de reserva se abrirá con un dispositivo de apertura automática.
El traje en sí me puede proteger del frío.
Esta área de la parte delantera tiene protección térmica.
En realidad, calentará el agua que envuelve mi cuerpo.
Cuenta con dos tanques de oxígeno redundantes.
Incluso si me hacía un agujero de 6 mm en este traje,
que es muy poco probable,
este sistema aún me protegería de la baja presión del espacio.
La principal ventaja de este sistema es el peso y la complejidad.
El sistema pesa unos 800 kg,
y si se compara con otro intento reciente de subir a la estratosfera,
utilizaron una cápsula.
Y en una cápsula, hay mucha complejidad increíble,
y pesaba alrededor de 1 360 kg
y para alzar 1360 kg a una altitud de 41 420 m,
que era mi objetivo de altitud,
se habría ncesesitado un globo de 13 a 15 millones de metros cúbicos.
Porque nuestro sistema pesaba 1360 kg
pudimos hacerlo con un globo cinco veces más pequeño que eso,
y eso nos permitió usar un sistema de lanzamiento mucho más simple
que lo que necesita un globo mucho más grande.
Con esto en mente, quiero llevarlos a Roswell, Nuevo México, el 24 de octubre.
Teníamos un equipo increíble que se levantó en medio de la noche.
Y aquí está el traje.
Este usa el cargador frontal que verán en un segundo,
y quiero mostrar un video del lanzamiento real.
Roswell es un gran lugar para lanzar globos,
pero también es un lugar fantástico para aterrizar con un paracaídas,
especialmente cuando se va a aterrizar a 113 km de distancia del lugar de partida.
Eso es un camión de helio al fondo.
Está oscuro.
Ya había pasado una hora y media con la prerespiración.
Y aquí se ve colocando el traje.
Se tarda aproximadamente una hora en poner el traje.
Los astronautas lo tienen muy bien con furgón de aire acondicionado
para ir a la plataforma de lanzamiento, pero yo tenía un cargador frontal.
(Risas)
Aquí se ve la parte superior. Se puede ver el globo allí.
Ahí es donde está el helio.
Este es Dave despejando el espacio aéreo con la FAA en 24 km.
Y ahí vamos.
(Risas)
Ese soy yo saludando con la mano izquierda.
La razón para saludar con la mano izquierda
es porque en la mano derecha está el corte de emergencia.
(Risas)
Mi equipo me prohibió el uso de la mano derecha.
El viaje es hermoso. Es una especie de Google Earth a la inversa.
(Risas)
Se necesitaron dos horas y siete minutos para subir,
y fueron las dos horas y siete minutos más pacíficos.
Intentaba en primer lugar relajarme.
Mi ritmo cardíaco era muy bajo
e intentaba no usar mucho oxígeno.
Se pueden ver cómo los campos en el fondo
son relativamente grandes en este punto,
y se me puede ver subiendo y subiendo.
Es interesante, porque si nos fijamos,
estoy justo en el aeropuerto, y estoy probablemente a 15 000 m,
pero estoy a punto de entrar en un viento estratosférico
de más de 190 km por hora.
Este es mi director de vuelo diciéndome que había alcanzado más altura
de la que nadie había logrado nunca en un globo,
y estaba a unos 1220 m de distancia del lanzamiento.
Así es como se ve.
Se ve la oscuridad del espacio, la curvatura de la Tierra,
el planeta frágil abajo.
Estoy practicando mis procedimientos de emergencia mental en ese momento.
Si algo sale mal, quiero estar listo.
Y lo principal que quiero hacer aquí
es liberarme y dejarme caer y permanecer completamente estable.
(Video) control de tierra. ¿Todo el mundo listo?
Cinco. Cuatro. Tres. Dos. Uno.
Alan Eustace: Ese es el globo que pasaba, totalmente inflado en este punto.
Y se puede ver un paracaídas estabilizador que demostraré en unos segundos,
porque es realmente importante.
Ahí está el globo pasando una segunda vez.
En este momento, voy casi a la velocidad del sonido.
No hay nada que me haga ver que es la velocidad del sonido,
y muy pronto iré tan rápido como jamás se ha hecho antes,
a 1323 km por hora.
(Video) Control de tierra: Hemos perdido los datos.
AE: Ahora estoy bajando en ese momento
y se puede ver el paracaídas que sale justo ahí.
En ese momento, estoy muy feliz de tener un paracaídas.
Pensé que era el único feliz,
pero resulta que el control de la misión estaba muy feliz también.
Lo realmente bueno de esto es el momento en que lo abrí.
Un amigo íntimo mío, Blikkies, mi chico para el paracaídas.
volaba en otro avión, y de hecho saltó
y aterrizó justo a mi lado.
Era mi compañero de viaje en el descenso.
Este es mi aterrizaje, pero probablemente es más propio llamarlo estrellarse.
(Risas)
Odio admitirlo, pero este no acercaba siquiera a mi peor aterrizaje.
(Aplausos)
(Video) Hombre: ¿Cómo te va?
AE: ¡Hola!
Hurra.
(Risas)
Quiero contarles algo
que no habrán podido ver en ese video,
pero una de las partes más críticas de todo era la liberación
y lo que sucede justo después de soltarse.
Y lo que intentamos hacer fue utilizar un paracaídas de frenado o estabilizador,
y había un paracaídas de frenado para estabilizarme.
Y mostraré uno de esos en este momento.
Si alguien ha hecho paracaidismo alguna vez en tándem,
probablemente utilizaron uno de estos.
Pero el problema con estas cosas
es que cuando se suelta, hay gravedad cero.
Así que es muy fácil que esto acabe enrollándose a su alrededor.
Y antes de que darse cuenta, uno puede estar enredado o centrifugado
o uno puede soltar este estabilizador tarde,
en ese caso se supone que se baja a 1290 km por hora,
y esta cosa se autodestruirá
y no será muy útil.
Pero a los chicos de United Parachute Tecnologías se les ocurrió esta idea,
y es un rollo que es así,
pero miren lo que pasa cuando se tira.
Está formando un tubo.
Este tubo es tan sólido
que se puede usar el paracaídas estabilizador y envolverlo alrededor,
y no hay manera de que se enrede alrededor de uno.
Y eso impidió un posible problema muy grave.
Así que nada es posible sin un increíble equipo de personas.
El núcleo estaba compuesto de unas 20 personas
que trabajaron en esto los tres años,
y eran increíbles.
La gente me preguntaba cuál era la mejor parte de todo esto
y fue la oportunidad de trabajar con los mejores expertos
en meteorología, en aeroestática, en tecnología de paracaídas,
en sistemas ambientales y en medicina de altitud.
Fue fantástico. El sueño de un ingeniero es trabajar con ese grupo de personas.
Al mismo tiempo quería agradecer a mis amigos de Google,
por apoyarme durante este esfuerzo
y también por cubrirme en los tiempos que yo no estaba.
Hay otro grupo al que quería agradecer, y ese es mi familia.
Hurra.
(Aplausos)
Constantemente les daba discursos de la seguridad de la tecnología,
y no escuchaban nada.
Era muy duro para ellos,
y la única razón por la que mi esposa lo aguantó
era porque volvía muy feliz tras cada una de las 250 pruebas,
y ella no me lo quería quitar.
Por eso quiero cerrar con una historia.
Mi hija Katelyn, mi hija de 15 años, ella y yo estábamos en el auto,
y estábamos por la carretera en el auto y estaba sentada allí,
y me dice: "Papá, tengo esta idea".
Y escuché su idea y le dije: "Katelyn, eso es imposible".
Y me mira
y me dice: "Papá, después de lo que acabas de hacer,
¿cómo se puede decir que algo es imposible?"
Y me reí y le dije: "Está bien, no es imposible,
es muy, muy difícil".
Y entonces me detuve un segundo y dije: "Katelyn,
puede que no sea imposible, ni siquiera muy, muy difícil,
es solo que no sé cómo hacerlo".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)